bună, mă numesc Olivia Lanes și bine ai revenit la Quantum Computing în practică, acesta este episodul doi: Quantum
circuits — vom acoperi mai multe subiecte în cadrul lecției de astăzi, dar ceea ce vreau să reții sunt următoarele trei lucruri: unu, ce sunt de fapt calculatoarele cuantice IBM
astfel încât să ai cel puțin o imagine de ansamblu în minte despre ce faci atunci când trimiți un job la unul dintre ele prin
cloud; doi, ce este Qiskit, ce sunt Primitivele și cum le putem folosi pentru a crea și a executa Quantum circuits
vom discuta de asemenea, la nivel înalt, diferitele tipuri de procesoare IBM Quantum disponibile și ce le distinge unele de altele; și trei,
în ultimul rând, fluxul de lucru tipic pe care îl urmăm pentru a rula experimente la scară mare — acesta include selectarea celor mai bune Primitive
pentru cazul tău de utilizare, maparea unei probleme într-un Quantum circuit și aplicarea suprimării și mitigării erorilor, care ne permit
să extragem cât mai multă putere din aceste mașini — acum există multă informație aici, dar rămâi cu mine
pentru că în curând vom pune totul laolaltă în contextul unor exemple reale — mai întâi să discutăm pe scurt despre qubit și despre hardware-ul cuantic actual
ca experimentator, îți pot promite că este fascinant și chiar ajută la conectarea punctelor să
vizualizezi ce se întâmplă de fapt când joburile sunt trimise la un calculator cuantic prin cloud — procesoarele pe care
le vom folosi sunt construite cu qubit transmon superconductori — iată cum arată un mic procesor IBM quantum
acum, aceste pătrate mici sunt chiar qubit-urile, deci există în total cinci pe acest chip — transmon-ul
în sine este un condensator și constă din două plăci de metal conectate în paralel cu un inductor neliniar numit
joncțiune Josephson — dar pentru a vedea joncțiunea Josephson trebuie să mărești și mai mult — este creată din două
straturi suprapuse de metal superconductor, iar acolo unde cele două piese se suprapun și se ating este joncțiunea — o joncțiune Josephson
este un element care poate fi folosit pentru a crea un atom artificial cu mai multe niveluri de energie și izolăm
cele două niveluri de energie de jos ca stare a qubit-ului — liniile ondulate de aici reprezintă rezonatorii cu microunde
practic linii de transmisie 2D cuplate la qubit — acum când programăm un gate, asta echivalează în esență cu alegerea unui
puls de microunde foarte bine calibrat, iar frecvența specifică, amplitudinea, forma și durata acestor pulsuri fac ca
qubit-ul să facă lucruri specifice — instrucțiunile pentru pulsul de microunde merg de la calculatorul tău la cloud și
apoi sunt citite și interpretate de electronica de control de la temperatura camerei, care preia acele instrucțiuni și fizic
generează pulsurile — le numim pulsuri de microunde deoarece toate se încadrează în banda de frecvențe a microundelor
care este în jur de 1 GHz — după ce cutiile de control de la temperatura camerei creează pulsurile, acestea călătoresc prin cabluri
în frigiderul de diluție și în cele din urmă la cipul nostru cuantic — semnalul intră în rezonatori prin
o legătură cu fir pe aceste pad-uri și apoi curge pe linia de transmisie în qubit-urile noastre — acum știu că toate acestea ar putea
fi puțin tehnice și aceste detalii nu sunt cruciale pentru a fi înțelese pe viitor, dar sper că acum
puteți măcar să vă imaginați sistemul fizic cu care urmează să interacționați — deci unde există de fapt aceste calculatoare cuantice?
ei bine, IBM are zeci de calculatoare cuantice în întreaga lume și ne-am actualizat recent flota pentru a
conține doar procesoare cu 100+ qubit-uri — după cum am menționat în lecția anterioară, unele se află într-un centru de date IBM
Quantum în nordul statului New York — acele sisteme sunt implementate peste tot în cloud pentru utilizarea tuturor și unele
sunt sisteme dedicate on-premise, complete cu toată electronica necesară pentru a le face să funcționeze, care sprijină partenerii noștri
din rețeaua IBM Quantum — acum să vorbim despre Qiskit, care este kit-ul de dezvoltare software open-source al IBM
conceput pentru a lucra pe calculatoare cuantice — de acum înainte mă voi referi la acesta ca Qiskit SDK — există de asemenea ecosistemul Qiskit
care este o colecție de tutoriale software și funcții care se bazează pe sau extind funcționalitățile de bază ale Qiskit, precum și Qiskit
runtime, care este un serviciu de calcul cuantic și un model de programare ce le permite utilizatorilor să proiecteze și să execute eficient
sarcinile lor cuantice folosind Primitive Qiskit — o Primitivă este în esență un mic bloc de construcție pe care
îl poți folosi pentru a proiecta circuit-uri mai mari sau un job — cele două Primitive care sunt cele mai importante pentru noi vor fi
sampler-ul și estimator-ul, despre care vom discuta mai detaliat în curând — dacă nu ai descărcat și instalat încă
Qiskit SDK, nu există moment mai bun ca prezentul — Qiskit 1.0 a fost lansat recent și este mai performant și
mai stabil ca oricând — deci pentru cei care abia încep, ați venit la momentul perfect — pentru cei
care sunt deja familiarizați cu Qiskit, va trebui să descărcați și să reinstalați cea mai nouă versiune — recomandăm să folosești
pip pentru a instala Qiskit și Qiskit runtime și să le rulezi printr-un Jupyter notebook într-un browser web la alegerea ta — deci va trebui de asemenea să
instalezi jupyter notebook sau Jupyter lab în cazul în care nu ai făcut asta deja — aceste instrumente sunt toate gratuite și
le poți configura și rula pe mașina ta locală fără niciun cost — asigură-te că adaugi Qiskit cu dependințele opțiunii de vizualizare
astfel încât să funcționeze cu Jupyter și să îți permită să trasezi grafice — va trebui de asemenea să configurezi un mediu virtual Python și există
instrucțiuni despre cum să faci asta pe pagina de instalare Qiskit, linkuită aici — odată ce te-ai familiarizat cu Qiskit și ești
gata să rulezi joburi pe calculatoare cuantice reale, va trebui să te înregistrezi la quantum.com și să creezi un
token API IBM Quantum — există de asemenea un link și aici pentru asta — o prezentare detaliată a modului de a face acest lucru — urmează toate
instrucțiunile din pagina noastră de documentație, după cum am menționat, sau poți urmări videoclipul de instalare Qiskit pentru coding linkuit aici
ambele fiind lincuite și în descriere — acum suntem aproape gata să începem să vorbim despre Quantum
circuits — deoarece scopul acestui curs este de a te învăța cum să-ți scalezi joburile pentru a fi rulate la scara de 100+
qubit-uri, cred că cel mai constructiv mod de a merge înainte este să luăm în considerare mai întâi fluxul de lucru general pe care îl vom urma — și cel mai simplu mod de a
înțelege un flux de lucru tipic de calcul cuantic este prin modelele Qiskit — modelele Qiskit sunt un cadru conceptual care le permite utilizatorilor să ruleze
sarcini cuantice prin implementarea anumitor pași cu instrumente modulare — aceasta permite sarcinilor de calcul cuantic să fie efectuate de
infrastructuri de calcul puternice și eterogene — acești pași pot fi efectuați ca serviciu și pot
include gestionarea resurselor, ceea ce permite compozabilitatea fără cusur a noilor capabilități pe măsură ce sunt dezvoltate — iată
pașii principali pe care utilizatorii experimentați Qiskit îi vor recunoaște probabil deja — primul pas este maparea — acest pas
formalizează cum luăm o problemă generală care ne interesează și găsim cum să o mapăm într-un calculator cuantic
sub forma unui circuit — în continuare optimizăm — în acest pas folosim transpiler-ul Qiskit pentru a routa și dispune
circuit-ul pe hardware cuantic fizic real — aceasta include traducerea gate-urilor cuantice individuale în secvențe
WEBVTT
de operații care sunt efectuate pe hardware, precum și optimizarea în dispunerea acelor gate-uri — în continuare vom
executa — Primitivele runtime Qiskit oferă interfața cu hardware-ul IBM Quantum care permite rularea circuit-ului transpilat
acest pas include de asemenea utilizarea tehnicilor de suprimare și mitigare a erorilor, care pot fi în mare măsură abstractizate față de utilizator — în ultimul rând, postprocesăm — în
acest pas, datele de la procesorul cuantic în sine sunt procesate, furnizând utilizatorului rezultate utile pentru problema originală — în esență, acest pas
înglobează orice analiză ulterioară a datelor care sunt obținute — acum suntem gata să discutăm fundamentul programelor cuantice
care sunt Quantum circuits — sperăm că ești deja familiarizat cu Quantum circuits, dar în cazul în care nu ești, poate vrei să verifici mai întâi lecția
trei, Quantum circuits, care face parte din „Înțelegerea informației și calculului cuantic", linkuită mai jos — vom
face doar o scurtă recapitulare aici — acum, un Quantum circuit este o rețea de gate-uri cuantice și măsurători legate
prin fire care reprezintă qubit-urile — Quantum circuits pot fi citite ca partiturile muzicale, de la stânga la dreapta, începând de la
timpul zero, care este tot în stânga — qubit-urile virtuale, adică qubit-urile care nu au fost încă atribuite unui
qubit fizic real pe un procesor, sunt listate în ordine crescătoare de sus în jos — odată ce configurăm circuit-ul nostru, putem adăuga
gate-uri — gate-urile cu un singur qubit, cum ar fi acest Hadamard gate de aici, afectează doar qubit-ul pe al cărui fir sunt plasate — gate-urile cu mai mulți qubit,
cum ar fi acest CNOT, afectează doi sau mai mulți qubit-uri legate de gate — în acest exemplu, starea qubit-ului unu se schimbă
în funcție de starea qubit-ului zero — după aplicarea tuturor gate-urilor, putem efectua măsurători
care determină scrierea rezultatelor în registrele clasice — o caracteristică deosebit de importantă a
unui circuit este adâncimea sa — adâncimea unui Quantum circuit este numărul minim de straturi de gate-uri cuantice executate în
paralel necesare pentru a finaliza calculul definit de circuit — pentru a fi clar, gate-urile cuantice pot fi executate în
paralel, adică exact în același timp, ori de câte ori nu au qubit-uri în comun — dar dacă două sau mai multe
gate-uri acționează pe aceiași qubit-uri, atunci nu le putem executa în paralel — suntem forțați să le executăm unul după altul, deoarece gate-urile cuantice necesită timp pentru a fi
implementate — adâncimea unui circuit corespunde aproximativ cu timpul necesar calculatoarelor cuantice pentru a executa
circuit-ul — deci cunoașterea adâncimii unui circuit este importantă pentru a ști dacă poate fi folosit pentru a rula pe un anumit dispozitiv sau nu — de asemenea, ne va spune dacă acesta
are o șansă bună de a produce un rezultat precis — în continuare să trecem la selecția unui procesor cuantic — IBM
a lansat recent o flotă complet nouă de procesoare, toate cu peste 100 de qubit-uri, și te poți loga pe quantum.com pentru a vedea
la care procesoare ai acces — procesoarele sunt toate numite după păsări din anumite motive, iar diferitele logo-uri
reprezintă diferite tipuri de procesoare — deci, de exemplu, acestea reprezintă procesoare Eagle, iar această pictogramă este un
Heron — numele procesoarelor specifice se găsesc de asemenea în partea de sus — sunt toate numite după orașe, dar asta
nu înseamnă neapărat că procesorul este fizic localizat în acel oraș — sunt doar nume — numărul de qubit-uri,
EPLG și CLOPS sunt de asemenea factori care sunt toți listați — vom trece prin fiecare dintre acestea
qubit-uri — acum acesta este destul de autoexplicativ — qubit-urile reprezintă doar numărul total de qubit-uri disponibile pentru utilizare pe acel procesor cuantic sau
QPU — EPLG înseamnă erori per gate stratificat, care măsoară eroarea medie de procesare a gate-ului într-un lanț stratificat de
100 de qubit-uri — în esență, vrei să fie cât mai mic posibil — CLOPS înseamnă operații de strat circuit pe secundă și
măsoară câte straturi ale unui circuit de volum cuantic, care este un circuit virtual, poate executa un QPU pe unitate de timp
— cu cât numărul este mai mare, cu atât putem calcula mai rapid — acesta este echivalentul cu ce înseamnă FLOPS în calculul clasic — acum aceste
diferite metrici pot fi mai mult sau mai puțin importante în funcție de domeniul specific de aplicare care te interesează — în continuare să discutăm la un nivel înalt
maparea în Quantum circuits — primul pas este pasul de mapare, care răspunde în esență la întrebarea: cum
traduc problema mea într-un Quantum circuit care poate fi rulat pe hardware cuantic? — acum nu există nicio îndoială despre asta —
maparea este o problemă dificilă și este un domeniu activ de cercetare — uneori, doar capacitatea de a lua o problemă computațională
și de a veni cu o secvență de gate-uri cuantice care ajută la rezolvarea ei este cea mai dificilă parte — nu există o
metodă sigură care garantează succesul, dar există linii directoare recomandate și exemple de probleme pe care știm deja cum să le
mapăm — prima linie directoare este să lași calculatoarele clasice să facă orice muncă la care sunt mai bune ele însele — testele
ușoare pentru calculatoarele clasice probabil nu vor beneficia de un calculator cuantic — calculatoarele cuantice sunt pentru probleme care sunt greu de rezolvat clasic — bineînțeles,
dacă aceasta este prima ta dată când folosești Qiskit sau un calculator cuantic, nu îți face griji să găsești o problemă computațional complexă — împarte-o
în probleme mai mici pe care poți învăța să le abordezi înainte de a merge direct la un proiect la scară utilitate — în continuare, translatează
rezultatele pentru problema ta pe care vrei să le măsori sau să le înțelegi într-o problemă de valoare de așteptare sau o problemă de eșantionare
— pentru majoritatea tipurilor de probleme, aceasta corespunde în esență calculului unei funcții de cost — o funcție de cost este o
funcție specifică problemei care definește scopul problemei ca ceva de minimizat sau maximizat și poate fi
folosită pentru a vedea cât de bine se descurcă o stare sau soluție de testare față de acel scop
această noțiune poate fi aplicată diverselor aplicații în chimie, machine learning, finanțe, optimizare și altele
de asemenea, reține că hardware-ul pe care îl vei folosi are o topologie specifică — unii qubit-uri nu sunt conectați
și unii sunt — și în cele din urmă va trebui să mapezi problema ta într-un circuit care reprezintă acest lucru — procesoarele IBM Quantum
folosesc ceea ce se numește topologie heavy hex, care echivalează în esență cu conexiuni de qubit-uri într-o rețea hexagonală pe care
o vom aprofunda mai târziu în curs — deocamdată, cel mai important lucru de reținut este că această etapă necesită
practică — trebuie să ai o bună înțelegere nu doar a problemei tale, ci și a capabilităților hardware-ului cuantic
— și vom parcurge un exemplu specific și un caz de utilizare mai târziu pentru a vedea cum pot fi cel mai bine
echilibrate — acum să discutăm cum să optimizăm un circuit pentru hardware-ul pe care l-am selectat — scopul general al
pasului de optimizare este de a mapa toți qubit-urile virtuali din circuit-ul nostru la qubit-uri fizice reale undeva pe
topologia procesorului — esența jocului este să reducem erorile cât mai mult posibil — pentru a face asta, trebuie mai întâi să
routăm și să dispunem circuit-ul nostru eficient — primul lucru de reținut este că nu toți qubit-urile sunt conectați, după cum
am spus deja — unii sunt de fapt departe unii de alții pe chip — deci trebuie să reducem sau să eliminăm interacțiunile la distanță lungă
ori de câte ori este posibil — poți aplica o secvență de swap gate-uri între qubit-uri vecini pentru a muta informația qubit-ului
în jurul chip-ului, dar swap gate-urile sunt costisitoare și predispuse la erori, deci pot exista modalități mai bune de a face asta — în continuare,
WEBVTT
dispunerea și rutarea sunt procese iterative și atribuie un qubit virtual din circuit-ul tău qubit-ului fizic de pe
hardware — poți face asta manual, dar există și instrumente în Qiskit care pot face recomandări pentru dispunerea fizică a
qubit-urilor bazate pe rate de eroare aproximative — în continuare, putem compune secvențe de gate-uri cu un singur qubit care acționează pe același qubit
într-un singur gate — și putem uneori scăpa de gate-uri inutile sau de combinații de gate-uri — de exemplu,
unele combinații de gate-uri pot fi reduse la combinații mai simple și uneori combinații de gate-uri chiar
echivalează cu un simplu operator identitate, deci le putem pur și simplu elimina — poți face asta automat folosind
transpiler-ul Qiskit sau poți face asta manual, gate cu gate, dacă ai un motiv bun pentru asta și vrei
mai mult control — odată ce am îmbunătățit dispunerea circuit-ului, rutarea și numărul de gate-uri, fie manual fie folosind transpiler-ul Qiskit,
de obicei dorim să vizualizăm circuit-ul pentru a ne asigura că timing-ul tuturor gate-urilor are sens — există un argument pe care îl poți seta în transpiler pentru a
vizualiza cronologia circuit-ului tău și a te asigura că totul este aliniat așa cum te-ai aștepta — acum să vorbim despre suprimarea
erorilor — suprimarea erorilor se referă la diverse tehnici care transformă un circuit în timpul compilării pentru a minimiza erorile
— este diferită de mitigarea erorilor, care are loc după ce circuit-ul a fost deja rulat, și vom ajunge la asta în curând — cele două forme cele mai comune de
suprimare a erorilor de care profităm sunt decuplarea dinamică și poly twirling — vor fi unele
detalii tehnice aici, dar poți reveni oricând la acestea mai târziu — deci, prima, decuplarea dinamică, este folosită pentru a
anula efectiv o parte din zgomotul care afectează qubit-ul prin aplicarea unei serii de gate-uri care împreună echivalează cu
operația identitate, cum ar fi secvențele XX, și al căror efect net este de a anula aproximativ canalele de zgomot care afectează
qubit-ul — poly twirling este o modalitate de a insera gate-uri aleatorii pentru a simplifica zgomotul mediu — aleatorietatea ajută
la prevenirea acumulării efectelor diferitelor erori și face zgomotul mai ușor de caracterizat
— acum această metodă formează și baza unei tehnici de mitigare a erorilor și vom discuta despre asta mai târziu
— din nou, există multă informație aici și nu îți face griji dacă nu se asimilează imediat — din fericire, o mare parte din aceasta poate fi făcută automat folosind transpiler-ul Qiskit
— transpilarea poate fi totuși complicată, dar transpilarea este un pas atât de crucial pentru a obține utilitate la scară
că necesită multă experimentare pentru a fi stăpânită și pentru a obține cele mai bune rezultate — acum vreau să fac o scurtă
paranteză pentru a discuta transpiler-ul Qiskit și capabilitățile sale puțin mai detaliat — voi face asta la un nivel foarte înalt și vom intra în detalii și vom vedea
câteva exemple mai târziu — în general, transpilarea este procesul de rescrierea unui circuit de intrare dat pentru a se potrivi
topologiei și dispozitivului cuantic specific și de a optimiza circuit-ul pentru execuție și rezistență la zgomot — de asemenea,
rescrie un circuit dat în gate-urile de bază ale acelui procesor cuantic specific pe care l-ai selectat pentru utilizare — Qiskit are patru
pipeline-uri de transpilare integrate și, dacă nu ești deja familiarizat cu optimizarea Quantum circuit, îți recomand cu siguranță să folosești unul dintre acestea
— pipeline-urile integrate — în mod implicit, transpiler-ul include acești șase pași: inițializare,
dispunere, rutare, traducere, optimizare și planificare — acum, inițializarea se referă la
orice trecere inițială care este necesară înainte de a începe să încorporăm circuit-ul pe backend — aceasta implică de obicei
desfășurarea instrucțiunilor personalizate și convertirea circuit-ului în gate-uri cu un și doi qubit — etapa de dispunere aplică
o mapare de dispunere a qubit-urilor virtuale din circuit la qubit-urile fizice de pe un backend — rutarea rulează după ce a fost aplicată o dispunere și
injectează gate-uri, cum ar fi swap gate-uri, în circuit-ul original pentru a-l face compatibil cu conectivitatea backend-ului
— a patra etapă este traducerea — în această etapă, gate-urile din circuit sunt traduse în setul de baze al backend-ului
țintă — în continuare este optimizarea — această etapă rulează bucla principală de optimizare
în mod repetat până când o condiție, cum ar fi atingerea unei anumite adâncimi țintă, este îndeplinită — avem patru niveluri diferite de optimizare
din care putem alege — ultimul este planificarea — această etapă este pentru orice treceri de planificare conștiente de hardware la un
nivel înalt — planificarea poate fi gândită ca inserarea de întârzieri în circuit pentru a ține cont de orice timp de inactivitate al qubit-urilor
între executarea instrucțiunilor — deci, după cum am spus, există patru niveluri de optimizare cuprinse între 0 și trei, unde
nivelurile de optimizare mai ridicate necesită mai mult timp și efort computațional, dar s-ar putea să obții un circuit mai bun
— nivelul de optimizare zero este destinat experimentelor de caracterizare a dispozitivului și, ca atare, mapează doar circuit-ul de intrare la
constrângerile backend-ului țintă — nu efectuează nicio optimizare — nivelul de optimizare trei
depune cel mai mult efort pentru a optimiza circuit-ul — cu toate acestea, deoarece multe dintre tehnicile de optimizare din
transpiler se bazează pe euristici, depunerea mai mult efort computațional nu duce întotdeauna la o îmbunătățire
a calității circuit-ului de ieșire — dacă ești mai interesat de asta, te rog să consulți paginile transpiler din documentația Qiskit
linkuită mai jos — acum suntem gata să discutăm execuția efectivă a unui Quantum circuit
— Primitivele runtime Qiskit oferă o interfață cu hardware-ul IBM Quantum și abstractizează de asemenea suprimarea
și mitigarea erorilor față de utilizator — Primitiva sampler returnează distribuția de probabilitate quasi sau numărătorile
reprezentând probabilitatea de a măsura anumite șiruri de biți, zerouri și unuri — Primitiva estimator returnează valorile de așteptare
ale observabilelor corespunzând mărimilor fizice — deci, cu un pic mai mult detaliu, sampler-ul rulează circuit-ul
de mai multe ori pe un dispozitiv cuantic, efectuând măsurători la fiecare rulare și construind distribuția de probabilitate
din recuperarea acelor șiruri de biți — cu cât mai multe rulări sau shot-uri efectuează, cu atât rezultatele vor fi mai precise
— dar asta necesită mai mult timp și resursele cuantice necesare pentru a rula — în mod specific, calculează probabilitatea
de a obține fiecare stare posibilă de bază standard prin măsurarea stării pregătite de circuit — estimator-ul Qiskit
folosește un proces algebric complex pentru a estima valoarea de așteptare pe un dispozitiv cuantic real prin
descompunerea observabilului într-o combinație de alte observabile care au baze proprii cunoscute și rulând — sub
capota Primitivelor se află tehnicile numite mitigare a erorilor — mitigarea erorilor este un termen umbrelă pentru toate acestea și
se referă în esență la tehnicile care ne permit să reducem erorile circuit-ului prin modelarea zgomotului dispozitivului în momentul
execuției — de obicei, aceasta rezultă în overhead de preprocesare cuantică legat de antrenarea modelului și
overhead de postprocesare clasică pentru a mitiga erorile din rezultatele brute folosind un model generat — dar în schimbul acestui
overhead, suntem capabili să obținem rezultate mult mai precise — există mai multe tehnici pe care le putem implementa pentru
WEBVTT
mitigarea erorilor și vom trece prin trei dintre ele mai detaliat — fii conștient totuși că acesta este un domeniu de
cercetare activă, deci vor fi probabil inventate tehnici noi și cele mai vechi vor continua să fie îmbunătățite — nivelul de
reziliență crește costul sau, cu alte cuvinte, timpul necesar pentru a-ți rula jobul — am spus deja că la
nivelul de reziliență zero, transpiler-ul nu face de fapt nimic circuit-ului tău, dar începând de la nivelul de reziliență unu introduce o metodă numită twirled
readout error extinction sau o numim T-REX pe scurt — twirled readout error extinction folosește poly twirling pentru a
mitiga zgomotul, ceea ce este ceva la care am atins deja — este o tehnică foarte generală și eficientă care
intuitiv vorbind face zgomotul mai puțin neregulat și mai ușor de gestionat — începând de la nivelul de reziliență doi,
introducem extrapolarea zgomotului zero sau ZNE pe scurt — aceasta este o tehnică populară cu care am avut recent mult
succes — ideea din spatele ZNE poate fi puțin surprinzătoare — de fapt adăugăm zgomot suplimentar
peste cel deja existent, dar ceea ce face asta este să ne permită să extrapolăm în direcția inversă pentru a
prezice cum ar arăta rezultatele dacă ar fi mai puțin zgomot — aceasta poate fi făcută în mai multe moduri specifice — de exemplu, putem
prelungi gate-urile pentru a le face mai lungi și astfel mai predispuse la erori, sau putem rula mai multe gate-uri care în cele din urmă
rezultă într-o operație identitate, deci circuit-ul nu se schimbă de fapt funcțional, dar eșantionăm intenționat mai mult
zgomot — trebuie totuși să faci asta pentru fiecare circuit și fiecare valoare de așteptare pe care vrei să o urmărești, deci
poți vedea cum poate ajunge să fie foarte costisitoare din punct de vedere al timpului necesar — un tip specific de ZNE se numește
amplificare probabilistă a erorilor — PEA pe scurt — odată ce am învățat un model de zgomot pentru un gate, PEA funcționează prin eșantionarea
erorilor din acel model de zgomot și injectarea lor deliberată în circuit — după cum am menționat, multe tehnici noi
continuă să fie dezvoltate și sperăm că vor fi implementate pe măsură ce vedem tot mai multe apărând — mai este o singură formă finală de
mitigare a erorilor pe care vreau să o discut, numită anulare probabilistică a erorilor — în loc să fie la al treilea nivel de reziliență,
PEC este o capabilitate specială pe care trebuie să o activezi manual în Qiskit deoarece resursele computaționale
necesare pentru ea nu scalează foarte bine comparativ cu celelalte tehnici de mitigare a erorilor pe care le-am discutat — tu
începi prin a învăța despre zgomotul care afectează circuit-ul tău rulând circuit-uri de învățare a zgomotului sau de caracterizare a zgomotului
pentru fiecare strat unic de gate-uri cu doi qubit care se află în circuit-ul tău — aceste rezultate îți permit să descrii zgomotul
în termeni de operatori Pauli — odată ce cunoști acești termeni de zgomot, îți poți modifica circuit-urile astfel
încât să aibă efectiv PEC-urile opuse integrate pentru a anula aceste canale de zgomot — în unele privințe, acest proces este
similar cu cel al căștilor cu anulare a zgomotului — cu toate acestea, această modalitate de a anula zgomotul este foarte costisitoare, cu un timp de
rulare care crește exponențial de rapid în funcție de numărul de gate-uri, deci ar putea să nu fie cea mai bună alegere pentru un circuit foarte mare — am
ajuns acum la etapa finală: postprocesarea — la final, dacă ai făcut o treabă bună și ai utilizat tehnici adecvate de mitigare a erorilor,
s-ar putea să vezi răspunsul tău final schimbându-se, la fel ca în această figură — o distribuție nemitigată
arătată în violet este destul de departe de valoarea adevărată așteptată arătată aici prin această linie — cu toate acestea, odată ce aplicăm mitigarea erorilor
obținem o distribuție mitigată arătată aici în albastru, care atinge vârful mult mai aproape de valoarea adevărată — acum,
toate acestea vin la un cost, și aici putem vedea că varianța sau lățimea distribuției este crescută, ceea ce
nu este în general ceea ce vrei — dar totul vine la un cost — din fericire, putem ține cont de asta rulând mai multe
shot-uri, ceea ce face distribuția să se micșoreze înapoi la un nivel acceptabil de incertitudine — deci cam atât pentru această
lecție — pentru data viitoare, vom lua toți acești pași și îi vom pune laolaltă și vom lucra printr-un domeniu și un exemplu
de interes real de aplicare — există câteva lucruri pe care le pot recomanda să le facem până atunci — dacă nu ai făcut-o deja,
asigură-te că descarci și configurezi Qiskit 1.0 — poți de asemenea verifica lecția asociată pentru acest capitol și
episodul anterior din platforma IBM Quantum learning — și în ultimul rând, dacă ești interesat să aprofundezi mai mult și
să afli mai multe despre tehnicile de mitigare a erorilor, consultă una dintre numeroasele surse pe care le-am linkuit mai jos — până atunci, ne vedem data viitoare
[Muzică]